Aiden's
in California,
I'm a musician and a songwriter and I
really would like to know what makes
music so human and powerful in its
nature.
Thank you.
Well,
I didn't,
as you know,
I know everything.
I don't know why,
but it sure is deep within us.
Now.
I remember when I was in school,
people in psychology class talked about
dogs responding to octaves.
That is the doubling of the frequency.
And so there may be something to that
that,
uh,
there are natural residences that appeal
to us that as something to do with our
voices.
But I have also,
I mean,
I'm not an expert in this,
but I've been to China and people will
listen to sort of western disco music,
but other music like swing music,
um,
that,
that doesn't appeal to them if they
don't like it.
There's something about the traditions
that with tonal language speakers versus
us that uh,
doesn't Jive,
doesn't fit in.
But then in Japan it's not a tonal
language,
but they also got something that sounds
more like Chinese to me.
I don't know.
It is deep within us and I will say,
uh,
if you want to get to Carnegie Hall,
practice,
I will say scales are very important.
Do Scales.
That's what it's all based on.
Somewhere down there.
And uh,
if you're going to play the blues,
I'm looking at you with your guitar.
If you're going to play the blues,
you got to get a couple of minor chords
in there.
You got to have a major third and
seventh or something like that.
But I'm not sure why,
but it's got to be just ultimately based
on trying to attract a mate that's got
to be what's down in their
carry on it.